Hello, listener. I am just one of three here, but listen, that's all we're gonna do today. I got rid of the other two. They've been weighing me down and weighing us down really. Haven't we really just been dying to just chat? Just the two of us? So what'd you do today? I can't hear you. You know what? This probably isn't gonna work well. I just now realized what the value is of the other two guys. I can't actually hear you, the listener, so I will... Hey, let me go wake them up. Meanwhile, let's play some music. Here comes Marlis. Hey, guys. I have never met anybody that will sing as many songs that I don't know as you, which is not really saying a lot, because I don't know a lot of songs. But Paul, your music taste, where did it start?
你好，听众朋友们。这里本来有三个人，但听着，今天我们只打算做一件事。我把另外两个打发走了。他们一直拖我的后腿，说实话，也拖了我们的后腿。我们难道不是一直渴望好好聊聊吗？就我们俩？那你今天做了什么？我听不见你说话。你知道吗？这可能行不通。我刚才意识到另外两个家伙的价值了。我其实听不见你，也就是听众的声音，所以我得……嘿，让我去把他们叫醒。与此同时，我们来放点音乐。马利斯来了。嘿，伙计们。我从来没见过像你们这样唱这么多我不知道的歌的人，这其实也没什么大不了的，因为我本来就不知道多少歌。但是保罗，你的音乐品味，是从哪里开始的？
Really wide. It's really wide. So when that really popular Alanis Morissette song came out in 1995. Oh, sorry. I'm not up on my Alanis catalog. Yeah. Are you apologizing to me or to her? Well, she's a great person, but I'm just... Nice buyback. Nice buyback. She had a musical based on her. Yeah, she did. Thank you, Sean. Jagged a little pill. You like a lot of different music, which I love. I do. I like a lot of different music, and I like... As you know, I'm an indie music fan, and I'm a big indie music, and I like a lot of female-driven indie music. Why were you a little late today? Well, I wasn't a little late. Oh, because I'm usually early. It's usually Jason late. Is that where you're at? Yeah. Yeah, it's confusing. It's weird. Were
非常广泛。真的很广泛。所以当那首1995年非常流行的艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特的歌出来的时候。哦，抱歉。我对艾拉妮丝的作品集不太了解。是啊。你是在向我道歉还是向她道歉？嗯，她是个很棒的人，但我只是……不错的买回。不错的买回。她有一部以她为原型的音乐剧。是的，她有。谢谢你，肖恩。《小碎药丸》。你喜欢很多不同类型的音乐，我很喜欢这一点。我确实喜欢。我喜欢很多不同类型的音乐，而且我喜欢……如你所知，我是独立音乐迷，我是个超级独立音乐迷，而且我喜欢很多以女性为主导的独立音乐。你今天为什么迟到了一点？嗯，我没有迟到。哦，因为我通常很早。通常是杰森迟到。你是这个意思吗？是啊。是啊，这很令人困惑。这很奇怪。你是
you writing a fan letter to Sarah McLaughlin? Is that what delayed you? Oh, her name. I would have... I know that song, but I couldn't tell you who sings it. You just did. Do you know when they made that... When they put that Alanis Morissette song on... No, not Alanis Morissette. Sarah McLaughlin's song on two great Canadian artists, by the way. So thank you. I want to say to both of them, how's it going? Can you sing out of the blue? Can you sing like a Celine Dion song? Oh, here he is. You don't need to ask him twice. I'm waiting for you, because I know that my life... Is that... My heart will go on? Yeah, but none of the words. Probably, yeah. How about Chaudet? You got any Chaudet in there?
在给莎拉·麦克拉克兰写粉丝信吗？是因为这个耽误了你吗？哦，她的名字。我会……我知道那首歌，但我说不出是谁唱的。你刚才说了。你知道他们什么时候制作那个……当他们把那首艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特的歌放在……不，不是艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特。莎拉·麦克拉克兰的歌，顺便说一句，她们都是伟大的加拿大艺术家。所以谢谢你们。我想对她们俩说，最近怎么样？你能突然唱出来吗？你能唱席琳·迪翁的歌吗？哦，他来了。你不需要问他两次。我在等你，因为我知道我的生活……那是……《我心永恒》吗？是啊，但歌词一句都不会。大概吧，是啊。那《夏黛》呢？你那儿有夏黛的歌吗？
Smooth operator. Did you ever DJ for a local Ottawa radio station? First of all, don't say local and Ottawa to me, okay? I'm not local to Ottawa. You're from Canada, though. I'm from Toronto. Isn't that... And I'm not from the Burbs. I'm from downtown Toronto. I grew up in the city on the hardscrabble streets of T.O. Or as we call it, T-Zero, the capital of Ontario. I shot a movie there a long time ago, and I went to Tim... What is it called? Horton's. Tim Horton, yeah. I would eat there every day. Is that right, eh? Would you eat there every day? Yeah, because I didn't know where else to go.
《Smooth Operator》。你曾经在渥太华当地的电台做过DJ吗？首先，别跟我提“当地”和“渥太华”，好吗？我不是渥太华当地人。但你是加拿大人。我来自多伦多。那不是……而且我不是来自郊区。我来自多伦多市中心。我在多伦多那条艰苦的街道上长大。或者我们称之为T-Zero，安大略省的首府。很久以前我在那里拍过一部电影，我去了蒂姆……那叫什么？霍顿。蒂姆·霍顿，没错。我每天都在那儿吃。是这样吗，嗯？你每天都在那儿吃吗？是啊，因为我不知道还能去哪儿。
At Timmy's? Yeah. You know, they got a new line with Justin Bieber. He's got a new exclusive line. He's got some kind of collaboration with Tim Horton's, and I was a little bit jealous. Oh, really? So wait, is it his own latte or is it a doughnut? I don't know. Don't they do doughnuts there and coffee? Oh, but do they do doughnuts there or what? But you're gonna... First of all, you're gonna get in there, you're gonna get a double-double. Let me get, you know, and...
在蒂姆霍顿？是啊。你知道，他们和贾斯汀·比伯出了个新系列。他有一个新的独家系列。他和蒂姆·霍顿有某种合作，我有点嫉妒。哦，真的吗？等等，那是他自己的拿铁还是甜甜圈？我不知道。他们那儿不是卖甜甜圈和咖啡吗？哦，但他们那儿卖甜甜圈吗，还是什么？但你打算……首先，你进去之后，你会点一杯双份加糖加奶咖啡。让我点，你知道，然后……
Well, we don't have too much. It doesn't mean fuck off to me, eh? I'll just take the fucking double-double, eh? Get out of here. And on that note. On that note. Guys. Oh, Sean, I'm sorry. Are you scrambling to get to the guest who's... I guess their name is KN95? Is that the back of their credit card? No, it's the inside of their mask. Oh, the KN95 is hiding there. Oh, that's hilarious.
嗯，我们没有太多。这对我来说不意味着滚蛋，嗯？我只会点那杯该死的双份加糖加奶咖啡，嗯？走开。说到这个。说到这个。伙计们。哦，肖恩，我很抱歉。你是在手忙脚乱地找那位……我想他们的名字是KN95？那是他们信用卡的背面吗？不，那是他们口罩的内侧。哦，KN95藏在那儿。哦，那太搞笑了。
I didn't saw that. Well, this fella is today's remarkable. He performed at the Improv Olympic in Chicago under the name of the family with Neil Flynn. Do you guys know Neil Flynn? You do. I know Neil. Great improviser. I've known him many years. He also was one of the founding members. This might give it away to Will of the Upright Citizens Brigade. Uh-oh. He auditioned to be on Saturday Night Live, but didn't get the job, instead becoming the head writer of the show at 27 years old, which is crazy.
我没看见。嗯，这家伙是今天的主角。他曾在芝加哥的Improv Olympic以“The Family”的名义与尼尔·弗林一起表演。你们认识尼尔·弗林吗？你们认识。我认识尼尔。很棒的即兴表演者。我认识他很多年了。他也是创始成员之一。这可能会让威尔猜到，是“正直公民旅”的成员。哦哦。他曾试镜《周六夜现场》，但没被录用，反而以27岁的年纪成为了该节目的首席编剧，这太疯狂了。
He's been nominated for a ton of Academy Awards for both writing and directing. He's the funniest fucking guy I've ever seen in Proviso. I already know who he is. I absolutely love him. What's his name, Will? His name's Adam McKay. His name's Adam McKay. Don't look up. Adam McKay? The guy's good out of me because he's smart and funny and successful and kind. Wow. Please welcome Adam McKay. I know Adam McKay is the best improviser I've ever seen on a stage.
他曾因编剧和导演获得过无数奥斯卡提名。他是我见过最搞笑的即兴表演者。我已经知道他是谁了。我绝对爱他。他叫什么名字，威尔？他叫亚当·麦凯。他叫亚当·麦凯。《千万别抬头》。亚当·麦凯？这家伙很厉害，因为他聪明、有趣、成功又善良。哇。请欢迎亚当·麦凯。我知道亚当·麦凯是我在舞台上见过最棒的即兴表演者。
Is that true? I used to go to Ascot just to see McKay. Come on. Really? By the way, our heat is broken, so I'm wearing a scarf and a weird jacket. And no one told me I was going to be on camera, so I look like a crazy shut-in. But you can afford a space heater, at least, can't you? I mean, you're doing remarkably well. You've never looked more Euro.
是真的吗？我以前去Ascot就是为了看麦凯。得了吧。真的吗？顺便说一句，我们的暖气坏了，所以我戴着围巾，穿着一件奇怪的夹克。没人告诉我今天要上镜，所以我看起来像个疯狂的宅男。但你至少买得起空间加热器，不是吗？我的意思是，你做得非常出色。你看起来从未如此有欧洲范儿。
Oh, Adam, what a pleasure to have you. Yeah, it's so lovely to see you. Wait, is it really that cold in your place? It's freezing. It's like 55 degrees. You know how it is. What part of the country are you in? We're in North Dakota. I have a house up in Bismarck. No, we're in Los Angeles.
哦，亚当，很高兴见到你。是啊，见到你真好。等等，你那儿真的那么冷吗？冷死了。大概55华氏度（约13摄氏度）。你知道是怎么回事。你在国家的哪个部分？我们在北达科他州。我在俾斯麦有一栋房子。不，我们在洛杉矶。
You're in a second. What part of Los something are you like in Big Bear right now? I'm in Hancock Park. Yeah, it's pretty cold at Hancock Park. Are you really? So am I. Oh, are you really? Yeah. Do we both walk out of our rooms and walk towards each other right now on camera and embrace?
你等一下。你在洛杉矶的哪个部分，你现在在比格贝尔吗？我在汉考克公园。是啊，汉考克公园挺冷的。你真的在那儿吗？我也是。哦，你真的在那儿吗？是啊。我们要不要现在都走出房间，在镜头前走向对方，然后拥抱一下？
We've only ever done one shared camera interview, and that was Willie and Downey, right? Yeah, that's right. That was the only shared experience that we've ever had in life. Hey, big congratulations on yet another really good, really difficult movie to make. Don't look up. I just love that. I love that movie so much.
我们只做过一次共享摄像头的采访，那就是威利和唐尼，对吧？是啊，没错。那是我们一生中唯一一次共享的经历。嘿，再次祝贺你又拍出了一部非常棒、制作难度极高的电影。《千万别抬头》。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢那部电影了。
It's fantastic. It's a crazy one. Well, let's just start right there. I want to go start at the beginning. And I know you're probably bored to death talking about your life, but it's not boring to me or us or our listener. So, but just right off the bat, how did Don't Look Up come to you? How did you think of it?
太棒了。这是一部疯狂的电影。好吧，我们就从那儿开始吧。我想从头开始。我知道你可能已经厌倦了谈论你的生活，但对我、我们或我们的听众来说，这并不无聊。所以，开门见山，你是怎么想到《千万别抬头》的？你是怎么构思出来的？
Why all of those things? Because I'm fascinated by... Meryl Streep was like phenomenal as you know, go figure, but she was so fucking funny. You focus on Meryl Streep. He's saving the planet and you're talking about Meryl Streep? Well, I just saw the movie. It was so good. It is Meryl Streep.
为什么是所有这些东西？因为我着迷于……梅丽尔·斯特里普的表现如你所知非常出色，想想看，但她太他妈搞笑了。你关注的是梅丽尔·斯特里普。他在拯救地球，而你在谈论梅丽尔·斯特里普？嗯，我刚看完那部电影。太棒了。那是梅丽尔·斯特里普。
But Jonah Hill got real close to blowing her right off the screen though. My God, was he crazy? Everybody was great. Everybody was so good. So good. It came from the place. A lot of ideas came from, I got incredibly freaked out about climate. And how we're not doing a damn thing.
但乔纳·希尔差点把她从屏幕上挤走。天哪，他是不是疯了？每个人都很棒。每个人都太好了。太好了。它源于一个地方。很多想法来自于，我对气候问题感到非常恐惧。而我们什么都没做。
And it seems to be coming faster and faster. Right. And so I went through a period where I was reading some books. I saw the UN report and my wife was like, will you stop? And I was like, I don't think this thing is 80 years away. I think it's like five to 10 years away. And she's like, you got to do something because this is getting tiring. So I was like, OK, I'm going to write a movie.
而且它似乎来得越来越快。没错。所以我经历了一段阅读书籍的时期。我看到了联合国报告，我妻子说，你能停下来吗？我说，我不认为这事还有80年，我认为大概只有5到10年了。她说，你得做点什么，因为这让人感到疲惫。所以我说，好吧，我要写一部电影。
And I decided the better way to go rather than doing giant dystopic movie, which there's been plenty of and plenty of great ones, was like, God, can we laugh? I haven't laughed in about 10 years or five years. Certainly the last five years have been so brutal. So that was kind of the entryway into it. But little do we know in the middle of making it, we would get hit by a full on pandemic and a half. The movie would come true.
我决定与其拍一部巨大的反乌托邦电影，虽然已经有很多了，而且有很多很棒的，不如说，天哪，我们能笑一笑吗？我已经有大约10年或5年没笑过了。当然，过去五年太残酷了。所以这算是进入它的切入点。但我们没想到在制作过程中，我们会遭遇一场全面的大流行。电影成真了。
So yeah, it was a crazy experience. Michael Moore has done such a great job of doing the documentary version of all this information. But you had another example of making the medicine go down nice and nice and easy. By satirizing what is just really, really shocking, scary stuff. Yeah, Mckay, I was thinking that like, I remember a couple of years ago, you really were on this, I would say, sort of 80% of your Twitter feed and stuff that you've put out has been about climate change and this climate disaster that we're currently actually in.
所以是的，这是一次疯狂的经历。迈克尔·摩尔在制作所有这些信息的纪录片版本方面做得非常出色。但你还有另一个例子，通过讽刺那些令人震惊、可怕的事情，让药物变得更容易接受。是的，麦凯，我在想，我记得几年前，你确实在关注这个，我想说，你推特上大约80%的内容都是关于气候变化和我们目前实际上正处于其中的气候灾难。
We don't even know that we're in the disaster. We keep talking about the impending climate disaster. We're in it. And you've been talking about it for years. And I follow you on Twitter and you opened my eyes to when you started saying, forget everything else that you think is fucking important to you. This is the number one issue. And you really brought it into focus for me.
我们甚至不知道我们正处于灾难之中。我们一直在谈论即将到来的气候灾难。我们已经在其中了。你已经谈论它好几年了。我关注了你的推特，当你开始说“忘记你认为对你来说他妈重要的所有其他事情”时，你让我大开眼界。这是头等大事。你真的让我看清了这一点。
It's literally one of the only positive experiences on Twitter was how you brought into focus. And I started saying what you were saying out loud to other people. Like, no, this is the most important thing. You can be outraged by shit. And you can clutch your pearls all you want. But you're going to be doing it underwater and on fire at the same time if we don't do something. Yeah.
这真的是推特上为数不多的积极体验之一，就是你如何让我看清了这一点。我开始大声对其他人说你所说的话。比如，不，这是最重要的事情。你可以对烂事感到愤怒。你可以随心所欲地表现出震惊。但如果我们不采取行动，你最终会在水下和火中同时做这些事。是啊。
I mean, you guys have seen it. We have those fires over in Pasadena and in the middle of the pandemic, I had to tell my wife and kids, don't go in the backyard because the air quality index is like 350. My sister had to evacuate her house up in Portland because they had air quality index that was like 550. There was another part of Portland. This is like a year ago, a year and a half ago, that had an AQI that was like close to Chernobyl.
我的意思是，你们都看到了。我们在帕萨迪纳有那些火灾，在大流行期间，我不得不告诉我的妻子和孩子们，不要去后院，因为空气质量指数是350。我姐姐不得不从波特兰的房子里撤离，因为他们的空气质量指数是550。波特兰还有另一个地方。这是大约一年前，一年半前，空气质量指数接近切尔诺贝利。
Wow. And yet somehow we filtered. And you guys saw the fires that just happened in Colorado, which were horrifying, the freak tornadoes in Kentucky. In winter. So yeah, it's going down right now. And yet you turn on our news and they never, ever mention it. It's bizarre.
哇。然而不知何故，我们过滤掉了。你们看到了科罗拉多州刚刚发生的火灾，那太可怕了，还有肯塔基州那场反常的龙卷风。在冬天。所以是的，它现在正在发生。然而你打开我们的新闻，他们从来、从来不提它。这太离奇了。
And it's about Britney Spears. Did something happen with her though? What do you think? Then what would you, what would it look like? Do you think to make America or even the world go, oh, oh, oh, gosh, we do have to slide this right up to the top of the priority list? Because you would think, well, it's got to be some sort of catastrophic event. Well, we've got those like once a month.
而且是关于布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的。不过她发生了什么事吗？你觉得呢？那么你会，它看起来会是什么样？你认为要让美国甚至全世界说，“哦，哦，哦，天哪，我们确实必须把它移到优先事项列表的最顶端”？因为你会想，好吧，那一定是什么灾难性事件。嗯，我们每个月都有那种事。
And even if it doesn't happen in your backyard, you know, we've got televisions. You've got a window at any corner of the earth. You can see an example of it at least monthly. But it doesn't, there doesn't seem to be anything that really drives us to make a big, huge shift in one stroke that can affect change as immediate as it seems like society needs to have to be excited about anything. Right? I think it's day to day because, you know, we all have friends who work in news,
即使它没有发生在你的后院，你知道，我们有电视。你在地球的任何角落都有窗户。你至少每月都能看到一个例子。但它似乎没有什么能真正驱动我们一次性做出巨大的转变，从而产生社会似乎需要的那种即时改变，以对任何事情感到兴奋。对吧？我认为这是日复一日的，因为，你知道，我们都有在新闻界工作的朋友，
broadcast news, journalism, and I'm constantly annoying them and asking them, like, why are you guys covering this? Like, did you see this story? Oh my God, how is this not on the news? Yeah. And they'll always say, well, you know, it doesn't rate. Yeah. It's tough.
广播新闻，新闻业，我一直在烦他们，问他们，比如，为什么你们要报道这个？比如，你看到这个故事了吗？天哪，这怎么没上新闻？是啊。他们总是说，嗯，你知道，这没收视率。是啊。这很难。
Audience doesn't want to hear about it. I'm always like, well, too bad. Like no one wanted to hear about Pearl Harbor. No one was like thrilled with that. So I think the trick is a lot of these news outlets have to treat it as a day to day story as opposed to a once every two weeks, once a month story. Like every press conference you see with the president, someone should be asking, why aren't you doing something about climate?
观众不想听这个。我总是说，嗯，太糟糕了。就像没人想听珍珠港事件一样。没人对那个感到兴奋。所以我认为诀窍在于，许多新闻媒体必须把它当作一个日常故事来对待，而不是每两周、每个月一次的故事。就像你看到的总统的每一次新闻发布会，都应该有人问，为什么你不采取气候行动？
What's your climate plan? They should be doing having scientists on every night. I mean, we just had those temperatures up in Alaska that were broke the high record temperature for Alaska by 20 degrees, which it's like someone beating Hussein Bolt by like a half an hour in a race. But Adam, don't you think it's like, you know, some of these politicians, I feel like sometimes or even more often that if it's not affecting them directly or their family directly, that they kind of don't do anything about it.
你的气候计划是什么？他们应该每晚都请科学家。我的意思是，我们刚刚在阿拉斯加经历了那些气温，打破了阿拉斯加的最高气温纪录20度，这就像有人在比赛中以半小时的优势击败了侯赛因·博尔特。但亚当，你不觉得吗，你知道，一些政客，我觉得有时甚至更频繁，如果它没有直接影响他们或他们的家人，他们就不会对此做任何事情。
It's even worse than that. In some cases, you know, it affects them directly. You got a guy, I think it was Devon Nunez, his house burned out from the freak fires. Really? And a week later, he was saying, yeah, we're not sure about climate change. I mean, you know, the answer is simple. It's big, dirty money, you know, fossil fuel pays off a lot of people. They buy a lot of advertising on the news.
甚至比那更糟。在某些情况下，你知道，它直接影响了他们。有个家伙，我想是德文·努内斯，他的房子在反常的火灾中烧毁了。真的吗？一周后，他说，是的，我们不确定气候变化。我的意思是，你知道，答案很简单。这是巨大的、肮脏的金钱，你知道，化石燃料收买了很多人。他们在新闻上买了很多广告。
And I think I don't think individual people are like, oh, I won't do stories on climate change because we get advertising money. I don't think people think like that. But, you know, if you're living in a house where, like, you know, your monthly mortgage is paid for by clowns, you're going to be a little nicer to clowns. You're going to be like, they're not that creepy, right? Is it also that any sort of change that we like, if we were to have change start today that really none of us are going to reap the benefits of that change
而且我认为我不认为个人会说，哦，我不会做关于气候变化的报道，因为我们得到了广告费。我不认为人们会那样想。但是，你知道，如果你住在一栋房子里，比如，你知道，你的月供是由小丑支付的，你会对小丑好一点。你会觉得，他们没那么令人毛骨悚然，对吧？这也是因为我们喜欢的任何改变，如果我们今天开始改变，实际上我们中没有人会享受到这种改变的好处
until after we're dead? Is that the bad news about all this is that it's not it's not exciting enough to to the voting public because they're not really going to see a huge change until the next generation? Or is that even a wrong statement? You know, some of this change will affect us soon. I mean, you know, there's some technology out there about carbon removal. And don't get me wrong.
直到我们死后？关于这一切的坏消息是，它对投票公众来说不够令人兴奋，因为他们直到下一代才真正看到巨大的变化吗？还是说这甚至是一个错误的陈述？你知道，其中一些变化很快就会影响我们。我的意思是，你知道，有一些关于碳去除的技术。别误会我。
The number one thing we need to do is stop producing CO2 and stop fossil fuels. That's number one. But there is some interesting technology out there. There's a group over in UCLA that can remove CO2 from the ocean. They have some technology that looks really promising. Well, what if we, you know, we're not really at war with anyone? What if you chucked $20 billion at that and tried to scale it up in addition to getting rid of fossil fuels and converting to solar and wind?
我们需要做的第一件事是停止生产二氧化碳，停止使用化石燃料。这是第一位的。但有一些有趣的技术。加州大学洛杉矶分校有一个小组可以从海洋中去除二氧化碳。他们有一些看起来非常有前途的技术。好吧，如果我们，你知道，我们并没有真正与任何人交战，如果你投入200亿美元，并试图在摆脱化石燃料和转向太阳能和风能的同时扩大规模呢？
So that would be something that if that hit in like three, four years and they modeled it for a rate of removal, that actually could affect our lives right now. And also the amount of CO2 is going up that we're producing. So you need to limit it for that. Well, everything in this country, everything in the world is is is really sort of driven by profit, as we all know. So like, you know, for instance, the war on sort of cigarette smoking this country and they find all the tobacco companies.
所以如果这在三四年内实现，并且他们模拟了去除率，那实际上可能会影响我们现在的生活。而且我们产生的二氧化碳量正在增加。所以你需要限制它。好吧，这个国家的一切，世界的一切，正如我们所知，确实是由利润驱动的。所以，比如，这个国家对香烟吸烟的战争，他们罚了所有的烟草公司。
It wasn't that they gave a shit as to whether or not you and I die. It's that they didn't want to pay for us to be in the hospital. Right. So that was what it was all about. It was all it was all about it was all driven by by economics. Well, then they figured out how to make money with the e-cigarettes. So they were like, OK, right. But that was long before when they had the huge when they had the huge cases when they find Philip Moore, it was then known as Philip Morris and all those companies.
并不是说他们真的在乎你和我是否会死。而是他们不想为我们在医院的费用买单。对。所以这就是它的全部意义。这一切都是由经济驱动的。好吧，然后他们想出了如何通过电子烟赚钱。所以他们就像，好的，对。但那是在很久以前，当他们有巨大的案件时，当他们罚款菲利普·莫里斯，当时被称为菲利普·莫里斯和所有那些公司。
And they and the companies, by the way, the cigarette companies are like, fine, well, no problem, because we can still sell enough cigarettes in Asia that it'll offset what we're paying and damages in the US. However, my point was this, is there what is going to be that thing? I guess we have to find the only thing that will get the attention. And Jason, maybe this goes to what you were saying is doing something like the CO2 removal, something that they can find a way to make that more profitable than fossil fuels.
而且他们，顺便说一句，香烟公司就像，好吧，没问题，因为我们仍然可以在亚洲卖足够的香烟，以抵消我们在美国支付的赔偿金。然而，我的观点是，什么是那件事？我想我们必须找到唯一能引起注意的事情。杰森，也许这和你刚才说的一样，做一些像二氧化碳去除这样的事情，一些他们可以找到方法使其比化石燃料更有利可图的事情。
Yeah. That is that going to be the only solution? Well, here's what's crazy. Renewable energy is cheaper and more efficient than fossil fuels. We crossed that line a couple of years ago. So the economics have caught up. It actually makes more sense for us to go to renewables. But what you're talking about is entrenched power and wealth. They have a hold of our government, our media.
是啊。那会是唯一的解决方案吗？嗯，疯狂的是。可再生能源比化石燃料更便宜、更高效。我们在几年前跨过了那条线。所以经济已经赶上了。转向可再生能源实际上更有意义。但你所说的是根深蒂固的权力和财富。他们控制了我们的政府、我们的媒体。
And even though renewables are more efficient, they're not going to let us switch. By the way, full disclosure, I'm on the corporate board for Marlboro. So you guys just know that. Yeah, so lay off a little bit. I'm a long time customer. And sorry, Sean, I just want to interrupt and just take a moment for our word from our sponsor, ExxonMobil. We'll be right back.
即使可再生能源更高效，他们也不会让我们转换。顺便说一句，完全披露，我是万宝路的公司董事会成员。所以你们知道这一点。是啊，所以稍微放过一点。我是长期客户。抱歉，肖恩，我只是想打断一下，花点时间听听我们赞助商埃克森美孚的话。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. Well, Adam, so on that point, and this is going to be, this is look, look, this accusation, I don't know who made it first. But and so I'd love to hear your thoughts on this and what your response is. Is it true that you once called Lauren and pretended to be Joe Tory? I love the gear shift. That was a hell of a gear shift. My neck hurts.
现在回到节目。好吧，亚当，关于这一点，这是，这是看，看，这个指控，我不知道是谁先提出的。但所以我很想听听你的想法以及你的回应。你曾经给劳伦打电话并假装是乔·托里，这是真的吗？我喜欢这个换挡。那真是一个地狱般的换挡。我的脖子疼。
So every Wednesday night, we would do read through at SNL. I'm sorry, Wednesday day. So you would stay up all night writing on Tuesday, you get no sleep. And then you read through 50 sketches. You guys know this, you've hosted and connected to the show. And Lauren would go in his office with the host and have dinner and take like four hours to pick the show. So I was head writer for about three years.
所以每个星期三晚上，我们都会在SNL进行剧本朗读。抱歉，星期三白天。所以你会在星期二整晚不睡觉写剧本。然后你读50个小品。你们知道这个，你们主持过并与节目有联系。劳伦会和主持人一起进他的办公室吃晚饭，花大约四个小时来挑选节目。所以我做了大约三年的首席编剧。
And then my last two years, I was, technically, my credit was coordinator of Falconry and I directed short films and I wrote sketches for real. By the way, it was actually my credit. And so I knew that Lauren was farting around in the room and kind of taking his time. So I was with Farrell and was like, Jesus, they've been in there for four and a half hours. Like I was like, at that point, I didn't care. So I was like, I'm going to call him.
然后我最后两年，我，技术上，我的头衔是猎鹰协调员，我导演短片，我写小品，真的。顺便说一句，那确实是我的头衔。所以我知道劳伦在房间里磨蹭，有点拖延时间。所以我当时和法瑞尔在一起，就像，天哪，他们在里面待了四个半小时。就像我当时，我不在乎。所以我当时想，我要给他打电话。
And so I just called his front assistant who didn't check the number. And I was like, yeah, it's Joe Tory for Lauren. By the way, no idea what Joe Tory sounds like. I'm assuming his voice is deeper than mine. And later, a friend of mine, Steve Higgins, told me Lauren cleared the entire room, made everyone get up, all the production people, the host, get out, get out. And he got on and he was so giddy. He was like, well, hello, Joe.
所以我只是给他的前台助理打了电话，他没核对号码。我就说，是的，我是乔·托里，找劳伦。顺便说一句，不知道乔·托里听起来像什么。我假设他的声音比我深沉。后来，我的一个朋友史蒂夫·希金斯告诉我，劳伦清空了整个房间，让每个人都起来，所有的制作人员，主持人，出去，出去。他接了电话，他非常兴奋。他说，嗯，你好，乔。
I'm like, hey, Lauren, you're having a good season. And I swear, he said, well, your season's not so bad either. And then I said, hey, listen, man, I got a nephew who's gay. And I just see the gay humor on the show, and can you knock it off? And there's a long beat and he just goes, is this McKay? And I got to give Lauren a ton of credit. He was cool with it. He actually laughed really hard.
我说，嘿，劳伦，你这个赛季过得不错。我发誓，他说，嗯，你的赛季也不错。然后我说，嘿，听着，伙计，我有个侄子是同性恋。我只是看到节目里的同性恋幽默，你能别这样吗？然后有一段很长的停顿，他只是说，这是麦凯吗？我必须给劳伦很多赞扬。他对此很酷。他实际上笑得很大声。
I never got shit for it. And you hear people treat Lauren like this giant, you know, Zeus on a mountain top, but he does have a sense of humor. God bless. He's funny, isn't he? And he likes and he really does at the end of the day, whatever is funniest will trump for the most part. You know, there's obviously politics, but like he does have a great sense of humor
我从来没因此惹上麻烦。你听到人们把劳伦当作山顶上那个巨大的，你知道，宙斯，但他确实有幽默感。上帝保佑。他很有趣，不是吗？他喜欢，而且归根结底，无论什么最有趣，在大多数情况下都会胜出。你知道，显然有政治，但就像他确实有很棒的幽默感
and he's quite funny, isn't he? You forget he was a writer for like laughing. He was an active writer on the show. He wrote the Beatles bit where we're going to give the Beatles $3,000. You remember this classic bit? If the Beatles come on the show and reunite, and Lauren came out and did it, I will give you a check for $3,000. You can decide who gets the smaller amount.
而且他相当有趣，不是吗？你忘了他是像《Laugh-In》那样的编剧。他是节目中的活跃编剧。他写了披头士乐队的那个片段，我们要给披头士3000美元。你还记得这个经典片段吗？如果披头士来节目重聚，劳伦出来做了这件事，我会给你一张3000美元的支票。你可以决定谁得到较小的金额。
Is it Ringo? Is it Harrison? That's up to you. And later, the story came out that John Lennon and McCartney were watching it and almost went down to the studio to reunite the Beatles. Hey, Adam, you know that you've had such success at such an early age. Did you like who validated you as a writer the first time? Like, what was that whole?
是林戈吗？是哈里森吗？这取决于你。后来，故事传出约翰·列侬和麦卡特尼在看它，差点去演播室重聚披头士。嘿，亚当，你知道你年纪轻轻就取得了如此大的成功。你喜欢谁作为编剧第一次认可你？就像，那整个过程是什么？
No, I grew up, I think age-wise we're all roughly in the same zone. So I grew up, I had a mom that was really funny, like laugh out loud funny. And then I had a dad who had a great laugh who loved comedy. And I also grew up as a latchkey kid. So I just grew up watching comedy and I was lucky enough in my generation that Letterman emerged, the Simpsons, stand-up comedy blew up. So I think for a lot of us, we just grew up in that zone. But I'll never forget Mrs. Sealy was my English teacher, my sophomore year in high school.
不，我长大时，我想年龄上我们大致在同一个区域。所以我长大时，我有一个妈妈，她真的很幽默，那种大声笑的幽默。然后我有一个爸爸，他有很棒的笑声，他热爱喜剧。我也作为一个钥匙儿童长大。所以我只是看着喜剧长大，我很幸运在我的那一代，莱特曼出现了，辛普森一家，单口喜剧爆发了。所以我认为对我们很多人来说，我们只是在那个区域长大。但我永远不会忘记西利夫人是我高中二年级的英语老师。
And you know, I went to a public school and for the most part, teachers barely clock who you are. Where did you grow up? I grew up outside Philly in a little, at the time, crappy town called Malvern. But now it's gotten kind of she-she. So I tell people I'm from Malvern, they're like, ooh, and I was like, no, no, no. I was there and Mrs. Sealy called me after class and she was like, you're a good writer. And it was the first time anyone had ever said that to me.
而且你知道，我上的是公立学校，在大多数情况下，老师几乎不注意你是谁。你在哪儿长大的？我在费城外的一个小镇长大，当时叫马尔文，是个烂地方。但现在它变得有点时髦了。所以我告诉人们我来自马尔文，他们就像，哦，我就说，不，不，不。我在那儿，西利夫人在课后叫我，她说，你是个好作家。这是第一次有人对我这么说。
So I give her a little throw a little love towards Mrs. Sealy. I love that. Did you find the transition from writing the short form, the sketches on SNL, a comfortable transition to long form in screenplays or did it take a bit? You know, it took, it's a really good question because certainly the jump from Chicago to SNL was fairly easy because all we did was improvise sketches, write sketches with the UCB. So that wasn't so hard.
所以我给她一点，向西利夫人表达一点爱。我喜欢这个。你觉得从写短篇，SNL上的小品，过渡到长篇剧本是一个舒适的过渡，还是花了一点时间？你知道，这是一个非常好的问题，因为从芝加哥到SNL的跳跃确实相当容易，因为我们所做的就是即兴表演小品，与UCB一起写小品。所以那并不难。
But you're right. The jump to feature scripts, I'll never forget with Farrell and I on Anchorman. You know what it was? It wasn't so much the form of the script because I had written a lot of scripts. It was just connecting with the audience in a different way because they're in a cinema, you know, they're in a theater watching a film. So the story I always tell is we screened the very first cut of Anchorman over in Westwood and all of DreamWorks was there, like Katzenberg, Walter Parks, all those guys.
但你是对的。跳到长篇剧本，我永远不会忘记法瑞尔和我拍《王牌播音员》。你知道那是什么吗？与其说是剧本的形式，因为我已经写了很多剧本。这只是以不同的方式与观众建立联系，因为他们在电影院，你知道，他们在剧院看电影。所以我总是讲的故事是我们把《王牌播音员》的第一个剪辑版在韦斯特伍德放映，梦工厂的所有人都在那里，比如卡森伯格、沃尔特·帕克斯，所有那些家伙。
And the movie Kilt and the original joke we had in the end was that Ron Burgundy's dog Baxter did not come back. It was actually a Doberman Pinscher that clearly wasn't Baxter, but Ron Burgundy was just like Baxter. And then you cut to Fred Willard go and let him have it. And that was the joke. So we screened the movie, big laughs, everyone's coming up to me, shaking my hand, oh my God, it's so funny.
电影很成功，我们在结尾的原始笑话是罗恩·勃艮第的狗巴克斯特没有回来。那实际上是一只杜宾犬，显然不是巴克斯特，但罗恩·勃艮第就像巴克斯特。然后你切到弗雷德·威拉德说让他拥有它。这就是笑话。所以我们放映了电影，大笑，每个人都走过来，握我的手，天哪，太搞笑了。
And then we get our numbers and you guys know it's zero to 100 for test screenings. Generally you want to be over 60. If you get up into the 80s, you're doing really good. Occasionally you'll see 90s, but you know, if you're over 60, you're okay. Any time you're in the 50s, 40s, it's bad news. You got to fix something, especially with a commercial movie. So they come up and they give us the scores and they're like, yeah, top box, 23, bottom box, you know, whatever it was, 20, I can't do the math.
然后我们得到了我们的数字，你们知道测试放映是0到100。通常你想要超过60。如果你达到80多，你做得很好。偶尔你会看到90多，但你知道，如果你超过60，你就还可以。任何时候你在50多，40多，都是坏消息。你必须修复一些东西，尤其是商业电影。所以他们走过来，给了我们分数，他们说，是的，最高分23，最低分，你知道，不管是什么，20，我算不出来。
But anyway, our score was 50. And everyone looked at each other like, what the hell? And the marketing lady said, you idiots, you killed the dog. And she actually said, you idiots. And I was like, yeah, but it's clearly fake. It's a joke. She's like, you can't kill the dog. So we went and we did reshoots and ended up leading to one of my favorite bits in the
但无论如何，我们的分数是50。每个人都看着对方，心想，这到底是怎么回事？营销女士说，你们这些白痴，你们杀了那只狗。她实际上说，你们这些白痴。我就说，是的，但这显然是假的。这是一个笑话。她说，你不能杀那只狗。所以我们去做了重拍，最终导致了我最喜欢的片段之一
movie where Baxter talks to a bear in the end for anyone who hasn't seen it is crazy. And we screened it and we brought Baxter back and our score went to a 76. Jesus. Did that make you mad at America? Did you think like, fuck you, everybody's so stupid that they can't just appreciate a joke and that they need that at the end? I mean, you know, from you guys have all done comedy in one form or another and you've done dramatic stuff as well.
电影里巴克斯特在结尾和一只熊说话，对于任何没看过的人来说，这太疯狂了。我们放映了它，我们带回了巴克斯特，我们的分数达到了76。天哪。这让你对美国感到生气吗？你有没有想过，去你的，每个人都太蠢了，他们不能只是欣赏一个笑话，他们需要在结尾那样？我的意思是，你知道，你们都以某种形式做过喜剧，你们也做过戏剧性的东西。
I always look at it like it's just the cards you're dealt. When it comes to an audience reaction, I never get too into why didn't they react this way or that way. So for me, it was just a learning thing. I realized, oh, with feature films, they carry more emotional weight because you're with these characters longer. And even if we think the style is ridiculous for to get, you know, more of an audience, that storyline, that emotional storyline actually really matters.
我总是把它看作是你得到的牌。当谈到观众反应时，我从来不会太纠结于为什么他们没有这样或那样反应。所以对我来说，这只是一个学习的过程。我意识到，哦，对于长篇电影，它们承载了更多的情感重量，因为你和这些角色在一起的时间更长。即使我们认为这种风格对于获得更多观众来说是荒谬的，那个故事情节，那个情感故事情节实际上真的很重要。
Even though when we would watch comedies, I loved airplane where the storyline really didn't mean a whole lot. So it's so funny. I didn't mind that lesson though, because then when we did Talladega Nights, I started using that more, the fact that the audience was invested and you could actually get laughs out of like, there's a joke at the end of Talladega Nights, which I'm sure no one remembers, but it was a big thing for me where Ricky Bobby early in the movie said he always leaves two tickets for his father that deserted him.
尽管当我们看喜剧时，我喜欢《空前绝后满天飞》，那里的故事情节并没有多大意义。所以这太搞笑了。我不介意那个教训，因为后来当我们拍《塔拉迪加之夜》时，我开始更多地使用它，观众投入的事实，你实际上可以从笑话中得到笑声，比如，《塔拉迪加之夜》结尾有一个笑话，我相信没人记得，但对我来说是一件大事，瑞奇·鲍比在电影早期说他总是为抛弃他的父亲留两张票。
And then in the end of the movie, Gary Cole walks up to the booth and says, I believe you got two tickets waiting for me. And the guy behind the booth says, Mr, these tickets have been waiting for you for a long time and we played this beautiful music. And then Cole pivots to camera and goes, who needs to, I got to and it's, it's a giant laugh. And so why are you crying? It's, it's once you kind of know it, you can play with them. And you guys have all done it.
然后在电影结尾，加里·科尔走到售票亭说，我相信你有两张票在等我。售票亭后面的人说，先生，这些票已经等你很久了，我们播放了这首美丽的音乐。然后科尔转向镜头说，谁需要，我必须，这是一个巨大的笑声。所以你为什么哭？一旦你了解它，你就可以和他们一起玩。你们都做过。
You've all been in stuff where people are invested in your characters. They love you. Yeah. And it's actually a good thing. Like you want that to happen. Yeah. And despite Will's weird, bizarre anger about it, it seems like Will's angry at emotions is what it seems like.
你们都参与过人们对你们的角色投入的事情。他们爱你。是啊。这实际上是一件好事。就像你希望那样发生。是啊。尽管威尔对此有奇怪、离奇的愤怒，但威尔似乎对情绪感到愤怒。
I am. I am. And Sean's crying about the story about the dad who came back and although he's never actually experienced the coming back part. So I've still got the two, still got the two tickets. So Adam, you know, you take the, the, the example of the, the dog at the end of, of, of Anchorman, but you know, your, you have been courageous enough with your movies that have followed that to make the target even smaller, that, that, that tightrope that you're
我是。我是。肖恩在为那个回来的父亲的故事哭泣，尽管他从未真正经历过回来的部分。所以我还有那两张，还有那两张票。所以亚当，你知道，你拿了《王牌播音员》结尾那只狗的例子，但你知道，你的，你随后的电影足够勇敢，让目标变得更小，那个紧绷的绳子，你在
walking between jokes and, and being either offensive or educational or whatnot. So your, it seems like your growth as a filmmaker was so fast and so good and so difficult, the, the, the execution, the difficulty. What do you attribute that to? You know, I always say like, I think the fact that I come from comedy and once again, you guys do as well in one way or another, there's something about how you're kind of linked to the world and people and what's going on and kind of the, for lack of a better word, gestalt of what's happening in the moment.
在笑话和冒犯或教育之间行走。所以你的，作为电影制作人的成长似乎太快、太好、太难了，执行，难度。你把这归功于什么？你知道，我总是说，我认为我来自喜剧的事实，再一次，你们也以某种方式这样做，你与世界、人和正在发生的事情以及某种程度上，用一个更好的词来说，当下正在发生的格式塔的联系方式有些特别。
And for me, the big turning point was really that 0708 collapse where I started going, wait a minute, this is no longer, we're now in a different era. And so I knew like, you can't keep doing the comedies that we have been doing, even though I loved making them and had the best time, I was like, that's no longer the world. And I got lucky to some degree, it was the big short when I read that book, I had one of those weird moments where I just knew how it should look and I knew that I was going to break the fourth wall and then I had the same thing with succession where the second I read that pilot script, I knew exactly how it should look.
对我来说，巨大的转折点确实是0708年的崩溃，我开始想，等一下，这不再是了，我们现在处于一个不同的时代。所以我知道，你不能继续做我们一直在做的喜剧，尽管我喜欢制作它们，度过了最美好的时光，我当时想，那不再是世界了。我运气不错，在某种程度上，当我读到那本书时，是《大空头》，我有那种奇怪的时刻之一，我只是知道它应该看起来像什么，我知道我要打破第四面墙，然后我在《继承之战》中也有同样的感觉，我读到那个试播剧本的瞬间，我就确切地知道它应该看起来像什么。
It's one of the best pilots I've ever seen. Oh, thank you so much. It is incredible. I mean, God bless Jesse Armstrong, that's one of the best written pilots I've ever read. And he came out of the Armando Anucci camp, yeah? Oh, yeah. He's from that whole team. Yeah.
这是我看过的最好的试播集之一。哦，非常感谢。这太不可思议了。我的意思是，上帝保佑杰西·阿姆斯特朗，那是我读过的写得最好的试播集之一。他来自阿曼多·伊安努奇阵营，是吗？哦，是的。他来自整个团队。是啊。
He's so sharp. Yeah. So I think that the fact that we're living in insane, all-time historic times, mixed with the fact that I have been directing movies and writing stuff and producing stuff, also mixed with the fact that I've just grown up, I've watched movies nonstop, like I'm a huge movie geek. But that was a whole different thing. I mean, you took the housing crisis and made it a comedy, but did it in a way that was
他太敏锐了。是啊。所以我认为我们生活在疯狂的、历史性的时代，加上我一直在导演电影、写东西、制作东西的事实，也加上我只是长大了，我一直在不停地看电影，就像我是个巨大的电影极客。但这完全是另一回事。我的意思是，你把住房危机变成了一部喜剧，但以一种
sophisticated and cynical and also used every department available to you as a director, as opposed to all those incredible comedies that you made that preceded it that were sort of high concept and tons of jokes and broad. This was a whole different thing that takes a whole career to learn. You did it in your next film. I mean, maybe it's part of it is my theater background too, because even there you're saying IO and UCB in Chicago, I'm sure you guys know enough about Chicago Theater that when you're there doing improv and you're doing comedy, you're not just doing that.
复杂且愤世嫉俗的方式，并且作为导演使用了所有可用的部门，而不是你之前制作的所有那些令人难以置信的喜剧，那些喜剧是高概念的，有很多笑话和广泛的。这是完全不同的事情，需要整个职业生涯来学习。你在下一部电影中做到了。我的意思是，也许部分原因是我的戏剧背景，因为即使在那里，你在芝加哥说IO和UCB，我相信你们对芝加哥戏剧了解得足够多，当你在那里做即兴表演和喜剧时，你不仅仅是在做那个。
We would do, I directed like a dramatic improv show. We would see Richard Maxwell's company, his experimental theater company called Cook County Theater Department, we saw like there was tremendous cool theater and the way Del Close always taught was you've got to know all the moves, all the styles. You treat yourself like you're working at the absolute top of your intelligence and then he would kind of wink and go and it makes it easier to be funny. And so part of that background was I had time in my early twenties to kind of soak up a lot of different styles that maybe that's part of it as well.
我们会做，我导演过像戏剧性的即兴表演节目。我们会看理查德·麦克斯韦的公司，他的实验剧团叫库克县剧院部，我们看到有非常酷的戏剧，德尔·克洛斯总是教导的方式是你必须知道所有的动作，所有的风格。你对待自己就像你在以你智力的最高水平工作，然后他会眨眨眼说，这让你更容易变得有趣。所以那个背景的一部分是我在二十出头的时候有时间吸收很多不同的风格，也许这也是其中的一部分。
That's great. So can you just for Tracey in Wisconsin, who's Sean sister, can you explain exactly who Del Close was and the kind of the impact and influence he's had on modern comedy? Yeah. Yeah. So it's a very strange thing because now we have the internet, but there was this scene in Chicago from the 60s, 70s, 80s, 90s, early 2000 that didn't exist really anywhere else in the world.
太棒了。所以你能为威斯康星州的特蕾西，也就是肖恩的妹妹，解释一下德尔·克洛斯到底是谁，以及他对现代喜剧的影响吗？是啊。是啊。所以这是一件非常奇怪的事情，因为现在我们有了互联网，但在60、70、80、90、2000年代初的芝加哥，有一个场景在世界上其他任何地方都不存在。
And it came out of Viola Spohlin created these theater games that were improvisational games and then another generation led by Del Close took those games and turned them basically for lack of a better description into improvised plays. And what he would do is he would rehearse you and teach you some general rules, sort of like running a motion offense in basketball. Like, well, if you have the pick, you pick and roll, you know, the give and go, there's certain moves that you do. And it was this incredible scene in the 90s, into the early 2000s, where every comic in
维奥拉·斯波林创造了这些即兴表演游戏，后来德尔·克洛斯带领的下一代人将这些游戏转化为了即兴剧。他会排练并教你一些基本规则，就像篮球里的动态进攻一样。比如，如果你要挡拆，就做挡拆顺下，还有一些特定的动作。那是在90年代到21世纪初的一段不可思议的时期，当时全国的喜剧演员，
the country, including Tina Fey, Dave Kettner, Chris Farley, like if you were doing comedy, you had to go to Chicago, it was the only place because there was no internet. And Del Close was the mad genius at the center of it. Yeah, it's pretty cool. And then you guys, you know, you guys would perform all the time and you, and obviously you were one of the, as Sean mentioned, one of the founding members, original members of UCB, it was you and Matt Walsh and Besser and Ian and Ali Farnakian, you know, during top hat times.
包括蒂娜·菲、戴夫·凯克纳、克里斯·法利，如果你想做喜剧，就必须去芝加哥，那是唯一的地方，因为当时还没有互联网。德尔·克洛斯就是其中的疯狂天才。是的，这很酷。然后你们经常一起表演，正如肖恩所提到的，你是UCB的创始成员之一，还有马特·沃尔什、贝瑟、伊恩和阿里·法纳基安，在“高礼帽”时期。
No, top hat times is a little bit later, as you know. And Polar, right? Wasn't Amy? And then Amy, which is how I first met you, and I used to watch, Adam, I met this too. I remember watching you, like, whether Del Close, Marathon or whatever, and Amy and I were just sort of first dating. And that ability, like, I just watched and wonder, I was too dumb to get into sketch. I didn't know what it was.
不，高礼帽时期稍微晚一点，你知道的。还有波拉，对吧？不是艾米吗？然后是艾米，我就是在那时第一次见到你，我以前常看，亚当，我也见过这个。我记得看你表演，不管是在德尔·克洛斯马拉松还是其他什么活动上，当时我和艾米刚开始约会。那种能力，我看着感到惊叹，我当时太笨了，进不了小品圈。我根本不知道那是什么。
Still dumb. I know, still dumb. And I wish I had, I wish I'd started there, I was, I always say that I was, when I was young, I was, I was young enough and stupid enough to think that being like serious seemed important. And I realized how, as I'm an older guy now, how dumb that was, because I wish you guys had that, there was that playfulness, there was that thing, there was that danger. And I remember you saying once too, like the people who are really funny, people who aren't
现在还是很笨。我知道，还是很笨。我真希望我当时就开始了，我常说，年轻时我太年轻也太蠢了，觉得表现得严肃很重要。现在我年纪大了，才意识到那有多蠢，我真希望你们当时有那种顽皮，有那种东西，有那种危险感。我记得你也说过，真正有趣的人，那些不那么有趣的人，他们身上没有危险感。等等。顺便说一句，你怎么敢谈论这个，天哪，你基本上给麦凯发了一封邮件，邀请他来这儿。我现在把它说长了，抱歉。所以这就是我看着你们的经历，在拍了这么多伟大的电影和做了这么多事之后，你怀念那个吗？你怀念那个吗？
that funny, they've got no danger in them. Hang on. How dare you, by the way, talk about it, Jesus Christ, you basically sent McKay an email at this fucking invitation. I made it longer now, sorry. So that was my experience watching you, that do you miss after all these great movies and things that you've done? Do you miss that?
你怀念每天做小品，面对世界上发生的一切吗？非常怀念。非常怀念。我告诉过我们公司的一位出色的制片人托德·舒尔曼，他以前经营萨莎·拜伦·科恩的公司。两周前我告诉他，我说，伙计，我们必须做一个小品节目。世界简直是，我把它形容为一个装满了鬣狗和长脚红酒杯的充气城堡。
Do you miss going and doing sketches every day and with everything that's going on in the world? So much. So much. I told, we have a great producer at our company, Todd Shulman, he used to run Sasha Baron Cohen's company. And I told him two weeks ago, I was like, dude, we have to do a sketch show. The world is literally, the world is like, I describe it as a bouncy castle full of hyenas
这就是我们生活的世界。我们竟然没在做小品节目，这怎么回事？所以不，我绝对怀念它。我的意思是，酷的地方在于，我们能做很多不同的事情。所以当我第一次试映《不要抬头》时，你们知道结局。那不是一个正常的结局。我记得那次试映让我多年来第一次感到如此紧张。
and long stem wine glasses. Like that's essentially, that's the world we're living in. And we're not doing a sketch show, like what's going on? So no, I definitely miss it. I mean, here's the cool thing is, you know, we get to do a lot of different stuff. So like when I first screened, don't look up, you guys know the ending. It is not a normal ending. And I remember being more nervous for that first test screening that had been in years.
所以只要你能从中得到什么，只要我能从我写的剧本中得到什么，就像我们做的那个关于Q的节目。我们制作了它。科恩·霍巴克做了它。在最后一集中，科恩·霍巴克揭露了谁是Q。这是我见过最不可思议的事情之一。我记得当时对那个节目非常紧张，心想，天哪，这些人会不会来找我们麻烦。
So as long as you're getting it out of something, as long as I'm getting it with the script I'm writing, like we did that queue into the storm show. We produced it. Cohen Hoback did it. And literally the guy in the last episode, Cohen Hoback, unvils who queue it. It's one of the most incredible things I've ever seen. And I remember being really nervous about that show, like, oh my God, or some of these people going to go after us.
所以你可以在其他地方得到那种感觉，但话虽如此，没有什么比在一个闷热的剧院里，挤着一百个人，没有剧本，直接开始表演更好的了。麦凯总是会那样，当场景正在构建时，就在那一刻，麦凯会介入，总是会说，对，这就是笑点。这就是笑点。我们马上回来。
And like, so you can get that in other places, but that having been said, nothing better than being on a stage in a hot theater with a hundred people jammed in there, no script. Let's go. And McKay would always, there would always be that moment, the scene would be building and then the guy right at that moment, McKay would step in and it would always be like, yes, that's the joke. That's, that's the joke. And we will be right back.
好了，回到节目。亚当，你会让演员在你的电影里即兴发挥吗，还是你更希望他们照本宣科？这怎么运作？我奇怪地对这一点很苛刻。你读我写的，你就是个木偶，你按我说的做，别搞什么阿尔菲式的即兴。不，我以这种方式出名，当你踩到我的底线时，你才得到绿灯。我唯一总是说的是，我们必须履行合同义务。先拍完剧本，然后我们总是可以乱来。
All right, back to the show. Adam, do you let or do you encourage improv on your movies from the actors or do you, would you rather them stick to the words and like, how does that work? I'm really, I oddly, I'm almost nasty about it. You read what I wrote me puppet, you say where you make an Alfie move, my words. No, I'm kind of known for you got the green light when you step on my, the only thing I always say is we got to fulfill our contractual obligation. Let's get the scripted and then we always screw around.
所以要么是我抛出额外的台词，要么是演员可以重新组织台词。我的天，乔纳在《不要抬头》里即兴发挥的量，还有梅丽尔·斯特里普、泰勒和凯特·布兰切特，基本上她们所有的片段都只是松散地围绕着我写的剧本，但她们把它变成了自己的东西。那真是太疯狂了。凯特·布兰切特出现在屏幕上时，我花了10分钟，真的10分钟。我转向我的丈夫斯科蒂说，哦，哦，那是凯特·布兰切特。那真是太疯狂了。
So it'll be either me throwing extra lines out, the actor can reorganize the lines. I mean, oh my God, the amount of improv that Jonah got in, don't look up and Meryl Streep and Tyler and Cape Lanshett were basically all their segments were loosely around was what I scripted, but they just made it their own. So that's fucking. It took me 10 minutes, literally 10 minutes when Cape Lanshett was on screen. I turned to Scotty, my husband was like, oh, oh, that's Cape Lanshett. That's fucking crazy.
我根本不知道是她。那太狂野了。你会很喜欢我正在做的新节目《谋杀镇》，我现在在打广告。哦，天哪。Netflix。但这就像一个，我们采用了英国的模式，那些家伙做得很好。这就像一个，像一个警察程序剧。我扮演这个警察，特里·西雅图，然后我们带嘉宾来，他们
I had no clue it was her. It was, it was wild. You'd really like this new show that I'm doing murderville, which I'm plugging now. Oh boy. Netflix. But it's like a, we took this format from the UK for these guys did a great job. And it's like a, it's like a, like a, like a police procedural. And I play this, this cop, Terry Seattle, and then we bring guests on and they have
没有剧本。特里·西雅图。那是个好名字。那是个好名字。我知道。我是好名字的粉丝。那是个好名字。我知道你会欣赏它的。
no. Terry Seattle. That's a good name. That's a good name. And I knew that. I'm a fan of good names. That's a good name. I knew that you'd appreciate it.
然后嘉宾来了，他们没有剧本，我们必须破案。我想整个剧组都有剧本，除了嘉宾，除了，是的，有剧本，除了嘉宾。但一旦嘉宾什么都没有，那就一切皆有可能，变成了一场疯狂的闹剧。最后。我知道你会喜欢那个的。去《谋杀镇》。
And then they, the guest comes on and they have no script and we've got to solve a murder. And I think that's the whole cast has a script, except the guest, except, yeah, there's a script and except for the guest. But then once, of course, the guest has nothing. So then it all bets are off and it becomes insanity. Last. I know you'd love that. To murderville.
你有一个新节目要上了，或者也许当这个节目播出时，它已经播出了。但是那个HBO上的湖人队节目，告诉我们你的湖人情结是从哪里开始的？是吗？顺便说一句，我甚至不知道你在那个节目里。威尔戴着湖人队的帽子。威尔戴着有史以来最大、最显眼的湖人队帽子。这简直就像违反了工作场所的行为准则。
You've got a new show coming on, or maybe by the time this airs, it's already been on. But the, the, the Laker thing on, on, on HBO, tell us about where did your, where did your Laker love start? Was it, was it? I didn't even know you were on the show, by the way. Will's got a Laker head on this. Will has the biggest, boldest Lakers hat on ever. It's almost like a workplace behavioral violation.
太激进了。等等，等等，在你回答之前，你知道作为一个加拿大人你不知道这个吗？我是个冰球迷。我是个超级篮球迷，但我20年前开始看大学篮球，差不多20年前，我在芝加哥，有一个即兴表演节，我做了独白，就像你一样，我想说，我和凯克纳还有几个人一起去的。我不知道。
It's so aggressive. Wait, wait, before you get to your answer, do you know that you don't know this as a Canadian. I'm a big hockey guy. I'm a huge basketball guy, but then I started watching college basketball 20 years ago, almost 20 years ago, I was in Chicago and there was some improv festival and I did monologues and it was like you, and I want to say like, I went with Keckner and a couple of people. I don't know.
你可能不记得了，但无论如何，我评论了NBA篮球，你狠狠地教训了我一顿，你说，让我告诉你，NBA篮球是最好的产品，你完全搞错了，你，我们在吃晚饭，我说，抱歉，我提到了它，但你让我欣赏了NBA篮球，我现在是它的粉丝。所以恭喜你。我说它是世界上最好的职业联赛，因为足球联赛是分裂的，只有一个NBA。
You probably don't remember, but anyway, and I made a comment about NBA basketball and you fucking read me the riot actor, you're like, let me tell you something, NBA basketball is the best fucking product and you got it all fucking wrong and you fucking, we were like at dinner and I went like, sorry, I mentioned it, but you made me appreciate NBA basketball, of which I'm now a fan. So congratulations. I say best professional league in the world because the soccer leagues are split up and there's only one NBA.
所以如果你是一个伟大的球员，你必须去那里。所以我们处于这个罕见的阶段，他们最终会创建其他联赛。但无论如何，湖人队的故事来自杰夫·珀尔曼写的一本很棒的书，叫《表演时刻》。正如威尔刚才所说，我是一个疯狂的篮球迷，我从小就一直在关注它。所以，我想我知道很多。然后我读了这本书，心想，哦，我其实知道得不多。这些故事太不可思议了。
So if you're a great player, you have to go there. So we're in this rare, they're going to eventually create other leagues. But anyway, Lakers came from, there's a great book by Jeff Perlman called Showtime. And I'm, as, as Will just said, I'm a crazy hoops junkie and I've been following it since I was a kid. So, you know, I think I know a lot. And then I read this book and it was like, oh, I don't know a lot. These are incredible stories.
所以我其实不是湖人队的粉丝。我在费城长大，所以我更像是76人队的粉丝，甚至在我小时候还是凯尔特人队的粉丝，因为我小时候住在马萨诸塞州的伍斯特。所以我只是热爱篮球，我能欣赏“表演时刻”的湖人队在某种程度上改变了美国的文化，当然也改变了篮球。他们也处于一个奇怪的转折点，就像，你知道，我们进入了里根时代，那是关于名人的时代。所以有所有这些关于阶级、种族和贫富差距的伟大议题。
So I'm actually not a Lakers fan. I grew up around Philly, so I'm more of a Sixers fan and was even a Celtics fan when I was a little kid because I lived in Worcester, Massachusetts when I was really young. So I just love hoops and I can appreciate that the Showtime Lakers kind of change culture in America, certainly change basketball. And they were also at this weird kind of hinge point where like, you know, we were going into the Reagan era, it was about celebrities. So there's just all these great issues of like class and race and wealth inequality.
同时，这是一个不可思议、酷炫的篮球故事。所以它非常有趣，但它有一些深度，天哪，我们玩得太开心了，尽管拍《不要抬头》很难，这显然是，你知道，我们正在经历的真实世界末日的寓言，我们在疫情期间制作了它。湖人队就像是反面。湖人队就像我和约翰·C·赖利、昆西·以赛亚，还有每个人，加比·霍夫曼，只是大笑，玩得很开心。所以这是一个非常酷的节目。
And then at the same time, incredible, cool basketball story. So it's fun as hell, but it's got some layers to it and oh my God, we just had the best time as hard as it was to make don't look up, which is obviously, you know, an allegory for the actual end of the world that we're living through that we made during the pandemic. The Lakers was like the opposite. The Lakers was like me and John C. Riley and Quincy Isaiah and everyone just Gabby Hoffman just laughing, having a great time. So it's it's a really cool show.
我想你们也会喜欢的，因为在视觉上我们有了一个巨大的飞跃。我认为这是一个非常不寻常、看起来很美的节目。所以我为你们感到兴奋。看起来你们在技术上也使用了许多不同的格式，对吗？我们发布了预告片。所以你们可能已经看过一点了。是的，我们使用了35毫米胶片，我们使用了Super 16。我们实际上弄到了一台1979年的摄像机，叫Ikigami。
And I think you guys will like it too, because visually we took a big leap with it. It's a very unusual, I think, beautiful looking show. So I'm excited for you guys. It looks like you use a lot of different formats too, technically, is that right? We put the trailer out. So you probably have seen a little bit of it. Yeah, we use, we use 35, we use Super 16. We actually got a 1979 video camera that called the Ikigami.
我们用它拍了很多。我们有时会混合静态照片。有时是当时的真实镜头。所以它有一种拼贴的感觉，非常酷。我们的摄影指导托德·本·哈泽尔，顺便说一句，小秘密，如果你想让你的东西看起来不错，就雇托德·本·哈泽尔，那是，那是对你的高度赞扬，但你是一个真正的摄影指导势利眼，以一种很好的方式，你能特别提到他。这太棒了。
We shot a bunch on that. We sometimes blend in still photos. Sometimes real footage from the time. So it's got this collage feeling that's really cool. And our DP, Todd Ben Hazel, who, by the way, little trade secret, if you want your shit to look good, how you're Todd Ben Hazel, that's, that's high praise from you, but you're, you're a real DP snob in a great way for you to single him out. That's amazing.
哦，这家伙是一颗冉冉升起的新星，你是百分之百正确的。我遇到过很棒的摄影指导，但他在这上面做了一种Ectochromic风格，当你看到它时，你简直想把胶片吃掉，但我认为你们会喜欢的。我得到的最高评价是来自那些说“我根本不关心篮球”的人，他们只是看完了它。他们喜欢它。哇。
Oh, this guy is a rising star and you're 100 percent right. I've had great DPs, but he did this ectochromic look on it that is just you want to eat the film when you see it, but it's, I think you guys are going to dig it. And the highest compliment I got is from people who are like, I don't care about basketball at all. And they just cruise through it. They love it. Wow.
杰森，当麦凯谈论这部电影时，就像我谈论你的勃起一样，我可以听他讲一整天。我可以保持。我可以保持。不，贝特曼的勃起。贝特曼的勃起。哦，等等。哦，贝特曼。
Jason, when McKay talks about this film as if I talk about your boner real quick, I could listen to him talk all day. I can keep it. I can keep it. No, Bateman's boner. Bateman's boner. Oh, wait. Oh, Bateman.
哦，抱歉。我想去。任何时候亚当说话，我都热血沸腾。亚当。我知道。我知道。亚当，你知道，从篮球到棒球，有人告诉我，你不是有个，就像回到洛恩那里，当你给洛恩打电话并假装是那个人时？
Oh, sorry. I want to go. Anytime Adam's talking, I've got full blood. Adam. I know. I know. Adam, you know, going from basketball to baseball, somebody told me, didn't you have like a, like back to the Lorne when you called Lorne and pretended to be that guy?
你给费城人队还是什么总经理打了电话，发生了什么？所以我当时在费城和保罗·F·汤普金斯在一起。我实际上。我爱保罗。我和保罗·F·汤普金斯一起出道。他是我的邻居，我的好朋友。我们在费城时大约19岁。我不知道那个。
You called the Phillies or something or the GM and what, what had happened? So I was in Philadelphia with Paul F. Tompkins. I actually. I love Paul. I came up with Paul F. Tompkins. He was my neighbor, my good friend. We were like 19 years old in Philly. I didn't know that.
是的。是的。我在一个在天普大学的单口喜剧圈子里，很疯狂，对吧？费城有一个非常好的单口喜剧圈子。汤普金斯当然是最有趣的，但汤普金斯太有趣了。他就像，还有其他人更像是路演喜剧演员，他们得到了更多的工作，但我们总是说，不，汤普金斯是最有趣的。他太他妈有趣了。
Yeah. Yeah. I was in a standup scene that was going to Temple University at crazy, right? There was a really good standups in Philly. And Tompkins, of course, was the funniest, but Tompkins was so funny. He was like, there are other guys that were more like road comics who got more work, but we were always like, no, Tompkins is the funniest. He's so fucking funny.
哦，他是最好的。所以我们在一个朋友家里。我想他叫托尼。他是个吉他手，我们和保罗、托尼还有我的朋友约翰·奥伊在一起，他也是个非常非常有趣的人。我们当时都嗨得不行。托尼有一些很好的大麻，在当时，你知道，它不合法，很难弄到。
Oh, he's the best. So we're at a friend of ours house. I think his name was Tony. He was a guitar player and we were with Paul Tony and my friend John Oi, who's also very, very funny guy. And we were all incredibly high. And Tony had a really good pot, which back then, you know, it wasn't legal, it was hard to come by.
我们当时真的很石化，世界变得非常缓慢和粘稠。我当时就想，我要给费城人队打电话做一笔交易。我拿起电话拨了查询台。我说，费城人队，前台，请。他们说，你想让我们转接吗？我说，是的，立即连接。所以他们连接了。
And we're just real. That stone where the world gets really slow and soupy. And I just was like, I'm going to call the Phillies and make a trade. And I picked up the phone and just dialed the information. And I was like, Phillies, front office, please. And they're like, would you like us to dial through? I was like, yeah, connect immediately. So they connected.
我对棒球了解得足够多，那是我还是个棒球迷的时候，我知道红袜队的总经理。所以我说，是的，我是卢·戈尔曼，找比尔·贾尔斯。他们说，请稍等。然后另一个人接起电话，他们说，比尔·贾尔斯办公室。我说，是的，我是卢，找比尔。顺便说一句，显然我不擅长模仿声音。那显然是我的棒球人声音。
And I knew enough about baseball, it's back when I was a little bit more of a baseball fan that I knew the GM from the Red Sox. So I was like, yeah, it's Lou Gorman for Bill Giles. They're like, hold please. And then another person picks up and they're like, Bill Giles office. And I was like, yeah, it's, it's Lou for Bill. By the way, clearly I don't do voices. That's clearly my baseball guy voice.
那是你给洛恩打电话的同一个人。他听起来像乔·托里。完全正确。那个女人说，请稍等。然后电话接通了，就像，嘿，卢，你好吗？我说，很好，比尔。你呢？他说，好的。
That's the same guy you call Lauren. He sounds like Joe Tory. Exactly. And the woman said, please hold. And then the phone picked up and it was like, hey, Lou, how you doing? And I'm like, good, Bill. How you doing? And he's like, all right.
那么今天我能为你做什么？我在脑子里想，天哪。我再次强调，我当时有点关注棒球。所以我认识一些球员，我说，你知道，我们有那个中继投手拉里·安德森，我们真的很需要内野手的帮助。你觉得怎么样？也许我们交换一下，你把兰迪·雷迪换给我们。又是一次长时间的停顿。
So what can I do you for today? And I'm like, in my head, I'm like, holy hell. And I'm like, once again, I'm kind of following baseball. So I know some players and I'm like, you know, we got that middle reliever Larry Anderson and we really need some infield help. What do you think? Maybe we flip, you flip Randy ready to us. And once again, long pause.
你是谁？然后我挂断了，心想，天哪。我告诉了我的朋友们，他们说，去你的，你没这么做。但我的朋友约翰·霍伊听到了那个电话。他说，他没开玩笑。他真的做了。那太搞笑了。我真希望你说的是，我是乔·托里的同性恋侄子。
Who is this? And then I hung up like, oh my God. And I told my friends who were like, screw you, now you didn't. But my friend John Hoy had heard the call. He's like, he's not kidding. He did it. That's hilarious. I wish you had said this is, it's Joe Tory's gay nephew.
是的。那会是。我们需要更多同性恋球员。亚当，我想谈谈你的播客，因为我知道你得走了。告诉我们，它叫《不要抬头》吗？播客？所以我们做了。它真的很酷，因为我们知道这将是一次疯狂的拍摄经历。
Yeah. That would have been. We need some more gay players. Adam, I want to get to your podcast because I know you got to run. Tell us about, is it called Don't Look Up? The podcast? So we did it. It's really cool because we knew it was going to be a crazy filming experience.
我们在拍摄《不要抬头》时不能带纪录片摄制组。所以我们带了一个播客团队，斯泰西、罗伯特·斯蒂尔、丹尼尔·瓦克斯曼和整个团队，不可思议的团队。他们做了一个完整的，有点像《黑暗之心》，但更有趣，或者《拉曼查的男人》。你知道，有很多关于电影制作的伟大纪录片。所以这是一个关于这部电影疯狂制作过程的播客，你知道，国会大厦被袭击，疫情，这些疯狂的明星飞进来，但他们不能离开房间。这只是一个接一个的故事。
We couldn't do a documentary crew when we shot Don't Look Up. So we brought a podcast crew in, Stacey, Robert Steele, Daniel Waxman and a whole team, incredible team. And they did a whole kind of hearts of darkness, but funnier kind of, or man from La Mancha. You know, there's all those great documentaries about making of movies. So this is a podcast about the insane making of this movie where, you know, the Capitol was attacked, the pandemic, these crazy stars flying in, but they can't leave their room. It's just story after story.
哦，酷。它叫《有史以来最后一部电影》，它在所有播客平台都有，它，它很酷。梅丽尔·斯特里普在里面，还有每个人，詹·劳伦斯，他们所有人。那真的太棒了。我正在听。好吧，亚当，非常感谢你来到这里。
Oh, cool. And it's called the last movie ever made and it's everywhere a podcast are, but it's, it's pretty cool. Meryl Streep's in it and everyone, Jen Lawrence, all of them. That's really great. I love that. I'm listening. Well, Adam, thank you so much for being here.
我知道你得走了。你真是一块宝石，一个搞笑的人。你是最棒的，亚当。我们都希望成为的那种人。你是个超级天才，伙计。天哪。我要带个空间加热器过去，因为你刚才被挡住了。非常感谢你做这些。
I know you got to run. And you are just a gem, a hilarious human being. You're the man, Adam. Somebody we all wish we were. You're the fucking mega talent, man. Jesus. I'm going to bring over a space heater since you just blocked away. Thank you so much for doing this.
非常，非常酷。荣幸，伙计。我爱你们每个人，这是那种，就像海陆大餐。你会说，哦，他们三个在一起？是的。所以说真的，伙计们，谢谢你们邀请我。是的。
Very, very cool. Pleasure, man. I love each of you individually and this is one of those things where like, it's like surf and turf. You're like, oh, all three of them together? Yes. So seriously, guys, thanks for having me on. Yeah.
谢谢，亚当。谢谢你所做的一切，亚当。感激不尽。再见，伙计们。爱你们。再见，伙计。再见。就像，你知道，我说他算是一个，不是国宝，
Thanks, Adam. Thanks for everything you do, Adam. Appreciate it. Bye guys. Love you. See you, pal. Bye. Like, you know, is it too much for me to say that he's sort of a, not a national treasure,
但他是一个现在能为我们提供真正有价值服务的人，因为他有能力，正如我之前所说，让良药苦口变得容易下咽。是的。我们可以照亮这些事情。我在想的是，我在想，有很多拥有平台或扩音器的人，无论什么，他们使用它，你知道，你发表获奖感言时，你会说，嘿，听着，做你该做的。这是一个在他的艺术中做到这一点的人。
but he's somebody that can really provide a really worthwhile service right now for us with his ability to make, as I said earlier, make the medicine go down easy. Yes. We can shine a light on these things. What I was thinking was, I was thinking like, there are a lot of people who have a platform or a megaphone, whatever, and they use it, and you know, you make an acceptance speech and you're like, hey, listen, do whatever you do. This is a guy who's doing it in his art.
他找到了一种方法把它融入到他所做的事情中，这已经成为传达信息的渠道，是在他的艺术中，你知道，无论是《大空头》还是其他什么。他一直在谈论，你知道，首先，气候变化是他的头等大事，但无论主题是什么，他都在把它放进去，这样信息就在里面了。这不仅仅是他试图赚尽可能多的钱时的脚注，他们就像，哦，嘿，还有，你知道，做这个。是的。是的。
He's found a way to thread it into what he does, and that's become the channel to get the message out, is in his art, you know, whether it's the big short or whatever. He's constantly talking about, you know, first of all, climate change is his number one thing, but whatever the subject is, he's putting it out so that the message is in there. That it's not just a footnote at the end of where he's just trying to make as much dough as possible, and they're like, oh, hey, and also, you know, do this. Yeah. Yeah.
他正在帮助我们审视自己，这感觉不像是在上课。是的。是的。我一直认为，你知道，我不记得是J.U.还是威尔提到了这样一个事实，当他从喜剧转型到除了喜剧之外还要谈论世界时，我记得看到他的名字，我不记得是什么了，但我只是想，亚当·麦凯，来自《周六夜现场》。等等，做了《大空头》，这是一个过程。
He's helping us look at ourselves, and it doesn't feel like classwork. Yeah. Yeah. I always thought, you know, I can't remember if it was J.U. or Will that touched on the fact that when he made the transition from comedy to saying something in addition to comedy about the world, and I remember seeing his name, and I can't remember what it was, but I'm just like, Adam McKay from Center Night Live. Wait, did the big short, it was a second of process.
但有趣的是，他一直，正如我提到的，就像他在《周六夜现场》写剧本时，或者他在UCB做即兴表演时，他一直，你知道，他就是最有趣的人。他太聪明了。是的，太快了。所以这说得通，因为他太他妈聪明，太他妈快了。是的。是的，我觉得除了他很快之外，我觉得我们必须快点结束。
But what's funny though, is he was always, as I mentioned, like when he was writing on SNL, or if he was doing improv at UCB or whatever, he's always, you know, he's just the funniest dude. He's so smart. Yeah, so fast. So it makes sense because he's so fucking smart and so fucking fast. Yeah. Yeah, I felt like in addition to him being fast, I felt like we had to get off fast.
所以，这可能就是我们现在必须做的，因为我们还有别的事情要做。所以也许快点结束，杰森，你想谈谈那个吗？你在说我高中的把柄吗？是的。那是我们可以，你想谈谈的东西吗？那不是那么笨。他以前也常说吗？那也是你著名的说法，这是你想谈谈的东西吗？
So, which probably we probably have to do now because we have other stuff to do. So maybe just get off fast, Jason, do you want to speak to that? You're talking about my handle in high school? Yeah. Is that something that we could, that you want to touch on? It's not so dumb. Did he used to also say that? That was also the thing you're famously says, is this something you want to touch on?
是的。你会对人们那样说。那更像是一个标签。就像你开车停下来，你会说，然后你指着你的大腿说，这是你想谈谈的东西吗？是的。你先从摇下车窗开始。是的。
Yeah. You would say that to people. That was more a hashtag. Like you'd pull up in your car and you'd say, and you'd point down to your lap and you'd say, is this something you'd like to touch on? Yeah. You start with a roll down the window sign first. Yeah.
摇下车窗。是的。是的。这是你想谈谈的东西吗？所以你们看了我最喜欢的他拍的电影之一吗，不是叫《迪克》吗？不。切尼。不。
A roll down. Yeah. Yeah. Is this something that you want to touch on? So did you guys see one of my favorite movies that he made was, wasn't it called Dick? No. Cheney. No.
《副总统》。是的，就是那个。我想知道他是否尝试过《迪克》，然后就像，是的，不，那个很好。那换一个呢？好吧。那《副总统》呢？如果他拍一部关于我们现任总统的电影，会叫什么？那么聪明聪明聪明不太聪明不太聪明不太聪明不太聪明是100%有机的，由罗伯·阿姆乔夫·贝内特、巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的聪明损失。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry应用程序中的Wondry Plus提前且无广告收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Vice. Yes, that's it. I wonder if he tried with Dick and it was like, yeah, no, that's good. What about a different one? All right. How about Vice? If he did one about our current president, what would it be called? Then smart smart smart less smart less smart less smart less is 100% organic and artisanly
副总统。对，就是这个。我在想他是不是试过用“迪克”这个名字，然后觉得，嗯，不行，这个好。那换一个呢？好吧。叫“副总统”怎么样？如果他拍一部关于我们现任总统的电影，会叫什么名字呢？然后是“聪明、聪明、聪明、不太聪明、不太聪明、不太聪明、不太聪明”，这是百分之百有机且手工制作的
handcrafted by Rob Armjolf Bennett, Barbaco and Michael Grant Terry smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由罗伯·阿姆乔尔夫·贝内特、巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的“聪明损失”。我们的下一集将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，也可以通过订阅苹果播客或Wondry应用中的Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。